yeah you ever have a plan for the day
and then you wake up and the day's like
hey here's to your plans here's a
completely different path so i woke up
this morning i was like okay time to
watch that adventure movie
the title of which i can't even think of
the internet was like boom here's a
deleted scene from the batman with the
joker which i know people don't really
know this about me i've held this in
i've kept this secret it's a little
known fact about me but now it's time
for you all to know the truth
i love the joker i just think he's the
greatest
shocking i know but this is a scene
where barry kyogen was cast as a joker i
didn't know that with the batman i i
went in blind i kept my nose out of the
rumor mill i didn't want to know
anything i didn't know the joker was
going to be in the movie or if he was
cast in the movie but batman goes to him
in arkham he's like hey there's a serial
killer the riddler just want your
thoughts which i know it does sound very
familiar it's very hannibal lecter very
silent of the lambs very red dragon man
hunter however you want to see it and
maybe that's a reason it was pulled you
already have homage to seven in the
batman now you have hannibal electra at
what point are you paying so much
tribute to other films that you're
you're kind of in the shadow of those
films rather than standing out as your
own film if that's the reason this scene
was cut i actually do understand that
otherwise that might actually be the
only reason i roll with because
the scene is actually pretty great just
in terms of joker and batman and the
dynamic between the two i thought the
scene was business but i'd love to hear
how you don't get a real clear look at
him ever there's a scene at the end
where you get a clearer look of his eyes
and then it moves up to his mouth you
can piece together his entire character
design
but you have to piece it together the
guy probably had a nice relaxing bath
and acid but more than that there is a
great joker batman dynamic in here in
this scene this five-minute scene i
think does a lot for batman's character
when batman gives him the file joker's
like oh that's right it's our
anniversary it was like okay so one year
ago apparently
this happened to him or at the very
least batman caught him a year ago which
shows that there's this whole thing that
happened before this this felt like the
first big thing that batman came up
against you know the riddler in the
movie the batman apparently not
apparently there was this whole joker
thing that happened before this but you
do feel like there's this olive branch
vibe going on where it's the reason
batman came to the joker maybe i'm
projecting maybe i'm filling in the gaps
i don't know i kind of don't care it's a
five minute scene i'm gonna see it how i
see it but there's something about the
way batman is interacting with joker
that almost screams hey sorry about your
face you want to help me catch a killer
yeah joker's obviously a psychopath
batman knows it but also joker addresses
the fact is like batman ain't too far
off a thing that's addressing the scene
which actually was addressed in the
movie i just think this scene
hammers it home the fact that
batman doesn't necessarily disagree with
where the riddler's coming from batman
to his core
feels these people that riddlers
punishing and killing
do deserve it to some extent as much as
batman's all like psychoanalyzing joker
joker's psychoanalyzing batman batman
looks really uncomfortable and angry
when joker brings that up again concepts
that were already in the movie but i
think the scene did a lot for that
concept also i think you see joker
projecting when he's
analyzing riddler and what he's doing
and he's talking to batman he's like
maybe he sees you as the main course i'm
like are you telling batman you see him
as the main chorus that's i like it you
know how when you leave a movie theater
it's quite possible the last feeling the
movie gives you is one that you take
home i personally feel well spoiler
alert for the batman now that you're
hearing me talk about a deleted scene i
it's fair to warn you talking about a
scene in the actual movie that's in the
actual movie that's in theaters that
joker cameo in the movie i hated i
thought it was weak as [ __ ] it just felt
like the movie was done filming and the
studio was like hey we need a joker
scene and since we apparently made you
cut this really sweet joker scene can
you have a joker cameo that's just kind
of half-assed and thrown in there just
felt like a [ __ ] reshoot where they
added the joker for the sake of joker
cause joker because people like me
have joker tattoos i don't have a joker
tattoo i would probably get a joker
tattoo try explaining that one all right
baby
you're looking at me weird yeah okay i
suppose the date's over now so comparing
these two scenes i mean it's not even
comparable this half-assed scene that
was in the movie and this really sweet
scene that fleshes out batman's
character using the joker just joker
operating in this context gave me the
feeling that i felt in the movie that i
really liked in the movie which is
gotham is alive these villains exist
and they're just they're navigating
three reasons i can think of as to why
this scene was cut uh one like i already
addressed too much homage too familiar
to hannibal lecter okay that's one
possible the second is that they didn't
want to commit to the character design
because at this like in the other cameo
you can kind of see what his face might
look like behind fog glass but you have
some wiggle room if you want to change
it i'm a sucker for continuity i hate it
when things are just straight up changed
in the sequels like the character
doesn't look like how the setup was for
the character okay maybe they didn't
want to commit to the joker's character
design don't know or three it's possible
the studio was like you need to have
joker in the movie and you need to keep
this movie under three hours and this
scene would set you over by about six
seconds can't have it remove it that
would be kind of ridiculous so
ridiculous in fact i can see a studio
insisting on that time restraints
themselves are ridiculous take it from a
man talking about a five minute six
second scene for over five minutes and
six seconds so anyhow that was today i
saw the scene i was like this scene was
really sweet and i wish it was in the
movie in fact i wish i hope
this scene is in the blu-ray release of
the movie i'd love to see how it fits in
where it fits in when it fits in but the
deleted joker scene from the batman have
you seen it what did you think about it
if you haven't seen it i put the link
below check it out and after you do see
it come back let me know what you think
that is to say whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you